this video is sponsored by keeps which
means we will hear more from them
somewhere in the middle of the video
hello everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel which is now titled
charulanazard YouTube changed a thing
where like you're at handle is whatever
your slash was I don't know if what I
just said will make any sense to anybody
who is not a YouTube content creator but
basically my URL was always youtube.com
charlesad and it's now slash at Charles
and then if you add me it was at Alana
Pierce so it's now Charles it's the same
everywhere people are very confused by
the change but I only change it to Alana
Pierce a year ago so I've just changed
it back effectively I took a break from
q and A's last month but we are back for
another gaming q a i do personal q and
A's on my other channel where the next
one that I do I intend to talk all about
my upcoming boxing match if you missed
that announcement I'll have that up in
the next couple of weeks I'm just
waiting
for something in particular to be able
to talk about but let's get to the
questions that you guys left on the last
video I love this question so I'm going
to start with this Luis Fernando
guatemara said question I'm someone with
limited Mobility uh we'll show you so
try to work out more and given you
already talked before about how fun and
beneficial doing exercise with video
games is I'm wondering which accessible
games with people with disabilities
looking to work out can you recommend
P.S thanks for your help in making games
more accessible you are welcome and it
is something I will never stop trying to
do that I feel very very strongly about
though there is no accessibility Awards
this year because God of War Ragnarok
is a game that I worked on that is up
for most categories and the part that I
did a lot of work on was accessibility
so um it felt wrong to do the Awards
this year so we're not so yeah I'm a big
proponent of using VR I use VR almost
every day to work out I'm currently
playing a game that does have a pricey
subscription um called Supernatural that
I absolutely love it's really really
great cardio but for a wheelchair user
of course there are different
accessibility so it's very difficult to
just recommend here's a game that's
great for all accessibility because
there are so many different facets of
accessibility needs but for you
specifically for somebody in a
wheelchair or even for somebody who
doesn't want to play while standing and
still get a good workout in beat saber
I'm currently playing Beat saber on
Expert Plus and plus three percent speed
is where I've gotten to and it takes me
about 45 minutes to get through the
first two sets of songs and I am very
sweaty by the end it is a hell of a
workout and you can play Beat Sabo
completely sitting down just moving your
arms and just moving your arms is still
great for cardio and there are so many
health benefits to cardio I'm probably
gonna make a video about this on the IRL
Channel because I think I kind of fell
into this too like I love weightlifting
and always have have and I really prefer
it to cardio I hate cardio but heart
health is really important and so much
of the fitness industry is like just
lift weights you don't need to
no it's very good for your heart to do
cardio your literal cardiovascular
health is important too I don't know why
I made that a song but I did so I
totally want to recommend beat saver if
you're looking for something specific in
VR it's a popular game you've probably
seen it before um but as you work your
way to the harder and harder and harder
levels it is a hell of a workout and
um so long as you have vulnerability of
your arms you will get that JW said what
do you think of IGN layoffs uh layouts
suck across the board and there have
been a lot of layoffs in
the games industry recently and the tech
industry recently and
um I was going to make a video about
this too actually on this channel where
after the Microsoft layoffs um there
were obviously a lot of people saying oh
this is the fault of Game Pass and it
certainly is interesting but the reality
is that we are seemingly heading to a
recession where there are going to be a
lot of layoffs across the tech industry
perhaps across every industry I'm just
not as informed regarding the news of
other Industries and IGN didn't have
layoffs for about eight years a really
long time that is a long time especially
for
a company that um appears to be on fire
so often
it's felt like something was falling
apart which to be fair is the reality of
almost every large company
they just like do a good job of hiding
it but that is a long time um that
doesn't make it any less brutal their
layoffs are awful and I feel very sad
for everybody who worked there but um
similarly to what I said about G4 when
G4 shut down I also like I even have
this take when I was at IGN and I don't
feel like anybody paid attention
I feel like the need for that kind of
media is decreasing there are more and
more Gamers so it's
a very slow Road uh but I feel like
majority of people who are trying to
consume gaming news now
um are going to do it from their
favorite YouTubers or they're going to
do it on Twitter or on Instagram I don't
see a lot of reason to go to an ign.com
um and I just don't feel that um IGN has
necessarily adapted to some of that
change in landscape where like now most
people they want to stay up to date with
things if they're not going to do it on
social media they're much more likely to
watch somebody live react to news on
Twitch or on YouTube then I think they
are on a website I think layoffs at IGN
were only indicative of the current
landscape but I feel like
um the whole of games media in general
probably has a little bit of an identity
crisis right now to be fair it's been a
long time since I worked in games media
at this point it's been five years now
which is a long time in that kind of
industry uh so what do I know that could
be way off base but that is my
perspective somebody who has always
loved video games and consuming video
game conversations I don't do any of it
really
via the big websites these days
um except for on Instagram where I do
definitely see a lot of my news and I do
tend to Source IGN when I'm making News
videos but um IGN is not ever where I
found the news you know it is time to
talk about keeps which is a subscription
service that helps men keep their hair
before I agreed to work with keeps in
the first place I reached out to a whole
bunch of friends who I know use keeps to
ask how they felt about it and to ask if
they felt like it was a good thing for
me to do and the answer was unanimously
yes everyone I know who uses it really
really likes it and encouraged me to
talk about it so that more men who might
be insecure about boldness are aware
that there are options to help of course
that's not saying it's something you
should be insecure about it's just that
there's an option if you are so if you
didn't already know it keeps office
clinically proven treatments to combat
the symptoms of hair loss because there
is no magic cure for baldness treatments
are FDA approved provider recommended
and delivered straight to your door
keeps treatment plans are affordable
typically half cost of Pharmacy prices
and all treatment plans are personalized
and recommended by a licensed medical
Provider Plus they include a year of
unlimited on-demand access to a
dedicated medical provider with 24 7
expert support of course important to
note so I want to reiterate that
treatment plans are clinically proven to
stop hair loss and ensure your hair is
as healthy as possible and their team of
dedicated providers Pharmacists and Care
Specialists are there to support you
along the way so whether you're looking
to prevent hail or stimulate hair growth
or just take better care of the hair you
have keeps as you covered you can easily
subscribe and get refill reminders so
you'll never run low on the products you
need to take care of your hair hair loss
stops with keeps to get 50 off your
first order go to keeps.com Alana Pierce
or click the link in the description
that's k-e-p-s.com Alana Pierce oh cool
tj9 said can you talk about how you felt
about forespoken yeah I have several
videos on full spoken because I was one
of the people who really didn't like the
trailer
then I played the first hour and I
didn't like the same things but I really
wanted to like dig more into it to
really figure out what its issues were I
felt like I could learn from it because
it is not a terrible game it's just got
some things that really bother a lot of
people myself included and I was like
let me dig into this more to like
understand what specifically I'm not
enjoying about this and like how to
pinpoint it and I think especially when
the the writing's being so heavily
criticized is a really interesting one
for me as a write-up to dive into and I
actually wasn't so bothered by her
dialogue in a lot of cases there were
some things that that did bother me the
main one really was that she often would
talk to people who she knows are from a
foreign land as though they should know
what Hell's Kitchen is you know like
she's like I'm from Hell's Kitchen are
we pretending that our protagonist is an
idiot and there's a lot of that that
makes the conversations very jarring
um because most people in another place
or a new place aren't going to pretend
that you know everything about New York
so I found her
um lack of malleability to the world
around her to be a little bit
off-putting but otherwise the quips uh
were not as bad as I felt they were in
the demo by any means they were fine a
lot of them were things that wouldn't be
dissimilar to something that Nathan
might say in Uncharted for example the
thing that I actually liked the least is
something that I feel very strongly
about and I remember when it got
announced that I got a job at Santa
Monica Studio I had like Angry redditors
be like what's your agenda just tell me
that what's your agenda and I answered
them honestly if I have any agenda when
it comes to making video games
it is um very different to full spoken
my agenda
is to tell as much narrative as possible
without cutscenes and this is something
I've been talking about on this channel
for a very long time I think the video
games are such a powerful storytelling
tool especially in the way that we can
tap into empathy and while I'm glad that
cinematic games exists and I don't want
those to go anywhere if I am to work on
something I am definitely going to push
for okay but how can we maybe have this
exact same conversation or the same
reveal while the player is actually
interacting with the world rather than
via a cutscene mostly I feel strongly
about it because I feel like that's
what's the coolest thing about video
games is that we can do that we are a
video game you can make cool things
happen video games can be more
um and we haven't even really tapped
into our potential where the limits of
that are concerned yet so the second
part of that is I think we're losing
audience retention especially now that
people are on Tick Tock or even YouTube
shorts seeing really really fast content
more often you are more and more often
seeing players put their phones down or
sorry pick their phones up as soon as
there's a cut if they have to be
interactive while the story is delivered
to them that is harder to do it's a
challenge in a bunch of ways because you
have to figure out how to get players to
still stay engaged and focus on the
story beats so that they don't miss them
while they are doing something else a
lot of challenge is that but um that's
my agenda well spoken the thing that I
liked about it the least was how
frequently it had cut scenes how
frequently you were paused or how
frequently you were unable to move
forward it's just to deliver cutscenes
that don't feel important enough to
justify how often those breaks exist so
I really didn't like that about it more
than anything else
um I think there are a lot of
interesting facets to the combat and I
feel like the demo messed that up by
throwing you in a little bit too quickly
it has some interesting complexity uh
there are things that I like about it I
like things about the world and the lore
I found interesting of this new world
which related to that on Friday podcasts
will be going up with Gary Witter for
the next episode of video game writing
101 there is no privilege listen this
week but we do have Gary Woodard joining
me for video game writing 101 who will
talk a little bit about his work on full
spoken so stay tuned for that but yeah I
didn't hate it the way that I feel like
most of the internet did but I feel like
that's like most of my stance most of
the time I definitely didn't like it and
I didn't want to play any more of it and
I didn't think it was the worst thing
I'd ever played either sometimes I think
I just like games more than most people
but I think it's more probably that I
started out reviewing games and I had a
contract that said I had to review one
game per week and in order to be able to
do that you have to play a lot of bad
games so I think that like my standards
for what games are bad is very different
to the average AAA or double a player
who only plays like very polished very
popular games like my sliding scale is a
lot broader because I played a lot of
like actually Bad Games darnside said
hey Alana I'm just wondering if you can
comment on why so many video games have
protagonists that talk all the time or
spoil puzzles uh I've spoken about this
on streams and I think I spoke about
this actually in my full spoken first
hour gameplay video I don't have any
first-hand experience in this this is
not something that I have done
I've not written a bunch of puzzle hints
or quippy protagonist stuff where they
talk a lot in fact I'm generally pretty
strongly against it but I believe for
the most part um and this is what I've
said before in the full spoken video is
um it's it comes down to play testing I
think that maybe a lot of players also
underestimate how important play testing
is like this is a tangent but you know
with games like Elden ring they're like
oh Todd only the best can do it but
really those games are extensively play
tested to be like the exact level of
hard to make sure that you can finish it
but you feel a sense of reward like it's
so meticulously designed to make sure
that you finish the fight in a certain
amount of time after a certain amount of
deaths games are designed for you to be
able to play them is what I'm saying the
puzzles are all designed for you to be
able to figure them out and there's a
balance between making sure that you
feel smart making sure that you can
finish things and play testing is where
all that fine tuning comes in the
protagonist giving away uh puzzles too
soon is something that has come out of
play testing I believe where it's either
that
um people felt they needed help or like
scored the game poorly in play testing
because certain puzzles were too obscure
and they needed more assistance and then
maybe it was ramped up to an extreme and
they added in a lot of hints and play
tested didn't criticize it but those are
not like organic things that happen for
no reason that somebody just wrote in
there
um that is a result of play testing and
if the general public doesn't feel the
same way the play test is due it's a
tough situation to fix because uh a lot
of play test is a very diverse and very
diverse backgrounds in terms of how many
games they play so they are pretty well
reflective of the general public I think
the solution is not to remove hints um
because that's even a good accessibility
option it's great for people who have
cognitive disabilities they should be
there but I do think that uh like some
games have recently actually high on
life did this you should be able to
decrease them
um or just across the board you should
be able to decrease the amount of
talking if that would be something you
prefer I think that's the coolest thing
about accessibility second time we're
gonna talk about that in this video is
so much of it is just like about making
games play the way that you want to play
them like I just feel like that's
awesome we should be able to customize
them as much as possible you can remap
all of your buttons I do it like every
time I get a chance now I'm like playing
games the way you want to play them it's
like such a unique part of our medium
and if you can have characters interact
with you in a way that you find more
tolerable I think that's really cool too
imagine a world where you're like a
really introverted person and you don't
like people talking a lot and you can
just scale back a story to like the bare
minimum I don't know how that works that
seems like it would be very difficult I
feel sorry for some narrative designs
who have to figure out how to program
that but like that level of
customization I think is something that
like all games should strive for we
should be able to be fully catered to
the individual player I think it's very
cool but yes generally I believe that
that is a result of play testing Frankie
one three one three he said hey Alana
curious to hear your thoughts on why
most Studios don't look at the way near
automata tells its story as a source of
inspiration for their own games to me
that game that is the game that is best
utilized being a video game and telling
its narrative and while the praise and
love for it is apparent and second
because of the industry I feel as though
its influence hasn't been as significant
as I'd anticipated I love Nero automata
I'm a very big fan of that game I love
the way it tells a story
um I think it's that near automata did
it it's not a great pitch to go into a
writer's room and say why don't we do
what this game did because the way near
automata tells the story is near
automata so for anyone who likes that
game uh you're going to walk away from
that game and be like oh well they just
did the Nia thing and while it is a
story about something about what
humanity is and the effects of mankind
and God and religion and love in your
automatic rules I think that the
identity of that game is so closely tied
to the way that it tells the story
um that somebody else doing it would
just be somebody else kind of making
something that feels a little bit too
similar to near automata but it's also a
very specific kind of Storytelling that
really only works in a certain setting
and I do think it's off-putting to a lot
of players and near automata probably
didn't have the sales reception to
justify going all out in that direction
all the time there are games that have
changed the way mechanics have worked in
storytelling
um works but I don't think near automata
is quite at the level of popularity to
like go to a publisher and be like we're
doing the near thing
when it didn't it I mean it was
successful but probably not successful
enough to justify
potentially putting off players by
making them play the same thing twice or
the 25 endings or however that works in
marketing but you should play it here
it's a very good game I really love it
bike and I said when you think we'll get
our first AI created video game well
plenty of parts of video games are
already made by AI problem with an AI
created video game I think is that the
AI would have to
have the foresight to create the video
game rather than just like devs telling
it to make a video game which I don't
even know if that's possible because
having AI of its own accord decide to
create a video game is a little
complicated because somebody has to fund
a thing that would consistently just be
creating of its own accord and um you'd
have to like pay for that's not cheap
video games generally a pretty
significant amount of assets that said I
don't doubt that somebody has probably
already made AI make a game and plenty
of parts of even the biggest AAA games
are sort of made by AI as it stands a
lot of QA testing is already helped
significantly by AI
um in theory a lot of bug reports in the
way that they're sent can be fueled by
AI so AI already helps with video game
development oh Nathan Nielsen said as a
game developer what do you reckon the
next big leap 2D to 3D level upgrade in
gaming will be will AI get to the point
where you could have totally unscripted
NPCs in a giant Bethesda style RPG AI
will totally get to that point yes I
think the potential the video games is
Limitless what do I think the next big
leap is obviously I'm a big advocate for
storytelling without cutscenes there are
a lot of games that are pretty close
though I think that there's a lot of
potential in the cloud I do think
there's a lot of potential in uh being
able to simulate entire cities
and have that load be streamed to you
rather than needing to sit on a hard
drive but it's a great question because
when moving so rapidly and that the
changes as a result of that become so
incremental I feel like it can often be
really hard to tell where we're going or
to tell how much progress we've made
right like the difference between the
first iPhone and the current iPhone is
pretty massive but because it happened
so fast and so in such an iterative way
it's very easy to forget that because it
wasn't just one huge leap and that's
just kind of the reality of gaming now
too that is going to be it for me today
everybody thank you for watching if you
want to leave questions for the next one
leave them in the comments below I will
see you next time bye